And action.
Name, please?
Thomas Middleditch.
5'10" and some change.
Okay, all right.
Did you wanna try it in the costume?
Sure, yeah, okay.
(wizard voice) It does not do to--
(normal voice) Hold on.
(wizard voice) It does not do to dwell--
(normal voice) What? It does not do?
It does not do.
This guy doesn't make any sense.
He speaks in riddles.
A little bit.
This is just original
dialogue of his from the book.
This is the original dialogue?
Yeah, the official script isn't out yet,
so we're just using official Dumbledore.
From what book?
I think it's from all seven
of the Harry Potter books.
What?
Okay.
I don't know what--
This is from a series of fantasy books
about a young magician.
Harry Potter--
Oh, Lord of the Rings?
Sorry, Lord of the Rings?
No, it's Harry Potter.
Okay.
Gandalf.
No, it's Dumbledore.
Doesn't matter.
Probably should be Gandalf.
I'll do it as Gandalf?
(wizard voice) It does
not do to dwell on dreams
and forget to live...
hobbit!
You shall not pass!
(normal voice) Gandalf.
That's a pretty good Gandalf.
All right.
Do you wanna do another quick one where
it's the same as like,
"you shall not pass,"
(wizard voice) eighth grade.
Okay.
(wizard voice) You shall not pass...
Eighth grade.
At Hogwarts.
Butterbeer!
Hobbit.
So I'm kinda doing 'em all, man.
Great, yeah.
(wizard voice) To the well-organized mind,
death is but the next great adventure.
Hobbit!
Okay, it is from Harry Potter,
not The Lord of the Rings.
Got it.
So there's no hobbits in it.
There aren't?
There aren't.
You sure it's fantasy?
Are you sure it's fantasy?
I got a beard on a beard.
I have my own beard, you know,
I just mean, he's supposed to be young,
he's supposed to be teen.
You know, actually I've got a whole,
I've got a whole thing.
(scrub voice) To the well-organized mind,
death is but the next great adventure.
(leather creaking)
Whatever.
Okay, we've got that.
Okay, we'll do another.
Yeah, we'll keep doing the lines.
(whooshing noises)
Yeah!
(loudly mimicking machinery)
Oh.
We're got an apple box
so we can bring you out.
Cause we're losing you out,
kinda lose the bottom on the ground.
Like this?
Yeah, that works there.
Ready?
Yeah.
(loud revving noises)
(screech)
(scrub voice) Oh, hey.
Happiness can be found even
in the darkest of times
if one only remembers
to turn on the light.
If anyone needs me,
I'll be in my room.
(laughter)
Try this thing where you're just gonna
sidle in and be like, "So was that good?"
So was that any good?
Yeah, that's good.
That was great.
I mean, I took a leap.
It's great, we got a lot.
Okay, great, good.
So you have enough?
Absolutely.
You don't want me to do anything again?
No, I think we're good.
Okay, cool.
Thanks.
Thank you.
See?
I sorta snap back, in and out.
Amazing.
Easy, yeah.
It's pretty easy for me, actually.
A lot of people say acting's hard on them.
It's easy. It's actually real easy.
Great.
Like the whole thing.
It was easy to get here.
Just, you know, ways.
And it was easy to drive here.
I'm just over the hill in Hollywood.
Cool, I think we got it.
Okay, great.
(laughter)